and next we're getting into the
halloween spirit
we sent the traveling news desk to the
spookiest place that we could find this
story is really cool i'm excited to take
you to this place because you all know
sleepy hollow and salem and amityville
but do you know about anoka minnesota
because it's the halloween capital of
the world
guess what we're going there because the
news desk is there here to give us the
scoop on america's spooky little town
please welcome lifelong resident and
halloween enthusiast gene hill james
hi girl
oh i'm here
to anoka
thank you so much gene for being our
ambassador to the halloween capital of
the globe we're so excited to see you
and i'm so excited to talk to you
i heard you're about to have a birthday
may i please wish you a very happy early
90s
what
[Applause]
thank you very
[Applause]
excited
much
it could you hear what we were i feel
young again oh come on could you hear
what we were talking about earlier with
with life and you know love and marriage
and divorce and all of that good stuff
yes
well i'm just interested because
oh good good
well i love your love story and your and
your family you met your husband um back
in the day and you have um
six grandchildren and nine
great-grandchildren you have a
tremendous love story may i ask the
secret to your love story
just to be happy every day
be
be cooperative with each other
and enjoy your family
i love life i've had a wonderful life
i started in anoka and here i am i'm
still in america
and you were born
[Applause]
1920 when anoka became the first city to
put a halloween celebration on the map
why did they start this celebration
because they had so many pranksters
carrying on different things that were
going on
and it happened that my dad
was one of those teenagers
so one time i asked him
dad what were you doing that was wrong
and he said it wasn't wrong we just
thought it was fun
so they decided that they would have
a parade and entertain the children
and so that was has happened and it's
carried on all these years 101 years
it's been going on
it goes on forever now we started all
with one little parade in the evening
and now we are
huge and people flock to anoka to watch
the parades
and everyone is welcome and everybody
relaxes and has a wonderful time
thank you jean thank you so much for
being our halloween ambassador
bringing anoka onto the map of the
drew's news
as well as the rest of the world and
celebrating a holiday that really is
about celebrating every unique
individual out there and that's why i
love halloween yeah can i ask one final
question from our halloween expert jean
is candy corn good or gross
oh yeah that's a good question
it's grossly good
i don't like candy corns jean i don't
get them but i get eugene
happy almost 95th birthday cheers to you
cheers
[Music]